non mi devi toccare hai capito minchia
Quindi questa è la mia cella Minchia
meglio delle popolari tu chi sei Oh ma
siete tutti lì giù qua dentro Io sono di
Torino quindi tutto stoà che c'ha sto
posto perché si vede il mare fuori Ah
bello per carità Però a me manca già il
fiume come Quale fiume Minchia il po le
basi zio Ho saputo che qui dentro c'è
pure una zingaro è vero Milos Ma sai
mica se è cugino di tamas Praticamente è
un mio amico finto di Nichelino sai che
loro sono tutti imparentati Ma chi è sta
gallina che canta Crazy compiamoci una
zarza che mi sto già chiudendo
di Napoli non hai capito È stato carino
Te lo giuro cardiol chi Oh mai visto
dicendo che mi hanno messo dentro tu mi
parli dei tipi ma ce la fai Ma vero fai
Ma niente c'è la mia amica Marika che
dice che è innamorata di uno che c'è qui
dentro ma tipo cardio Brava cardio Trap
Canta pure lui Oh ma questo è un carcere
minori e là Amici di Maria